hey guys Pete here this will be my
Westworld season 3 episode a preview
slash trailer breakdown video we're at
the season 3 finale already and last
week HBO announced there will be a
season for at least possibly as many as
six seasons according to The Hollywood
Reporter but let's not get ahead of
ourselves
this video will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the show
through the seventh episode of season 3
and I'm gonna be speculating about the
finale while breaking down the promo
trailer scene-by-scene now's your chance
to bail if you're not caught up or
interested in that type of speculation
before the season 4 announcement and
before this last episode aired I thought
we were racing towards the conclusions
for some of the series plot lines now
I'm not sure where we're at now there's
a lot riding on this finale how things
play out will be the difference between
a good season a Westworld
or a bunch of good ideas that didn't
really go anywhere I'm definitely
rooting for the former of those two
choices but I'd be lying if I said I
wasn't a little bit worried about
whether or not we're going to get there
episode 7 wasn't my favorite we learned
a lot of new information about what
motivates people but there was also just
a lot of stuff that didn't work for me
we know what motivates Erick after
episode 7
he wants the del o stata so that he can
edit or fix or cure cure with quotation
marks his brother however you want to
say it Dolores is the current obstacle
blocking his path because she knows
where that data is and we can gather
from this trailer that these two
opposing forces will clash I expect that
part of Dolores is overall plan involves
destroying Rehoboam but she hasn't
really outlined what she's trying to do
beyond vague ideas like a revolution or
ensuring the survival over kind the name
of episode 8 is chaos theory and the
description reads time to face the music
it looks like it will be 75 minutes long
but that could change in the past the
season finales were about 90 minutes so
this is shorter than those but longer
than a normal episode obviously there's
a showdown coming between Dolores and
Ciroc in that most of the characters
were aligned with one side or the other
but now we see char loris could be a
wild card
after losing hail
family her plan and allegiances are
unknown Ciroc was behind that so char
loris wouldn't be aligned with him but
it seems like she has a plan to do
something to undermine Dolores and so
maybe they both have the same enemy at
this point we also have the man in black
and Bernard out there they seem to be
important to Dolores his plan but it's
not clear how they'll fit into the
ending there's still one host pearl that
Dolores brought with her when she
escaped the park that is unaccounted for
we believe that's another copy of
Dolores that was believed to be in
Berlin based on what sera acts assistant
told him a couple episodes back on the
plane I'm sure we will find out what's
going on with that in the finale so
there's a lot of questions but this has
been a really straightforward season of
Westworld at the same time a lot of the
questions I have aren't what are people
doing but more on the lines of why are
they doing but yes for this season to
succeed this finale it's gonna have to
make it all come together in a
satisfying way as season finale trailers
often do it doesn't give us much to go
off in the trailer we see a lot of stuff
it's all kind of just these battles that
are gonna happen that we know are gonna
happen but let's break it down scene by
scene and look at what's there the
episode 8 trailer opens with riot police
in the streets we get the idea that
things have devolved in the time after
Dolores released everyone's insight
profiles
there's chaos if we look at this first
shot we see that looks like that the
screens behind it have been hacked we
get a shot of Caleb walking through it
he's moving with purpose taking in the
chaos and likely looking over a shoulder
at the same time we see a lot of
different banners and people are
protesting in sight obviously in this
one shot you can see the maze on this
sign that says rise up or something
along that lines this is really
confusing to me because I don't
understand how the idea of the maze
would get outside the park if the hosts
didn't do that
hopefully they'll explain that because
we've seen it in previous episodes
spray-painted on walls and things and I
can't really come up with a good
explanation of why the maze would be
outside of Westworld in voiceover we
hear Barnard say what's about to happen
was always going to happen and I think
as you see Caleb looking around at
everything that's happening that he's
probably making the connection that he
he was a part of this like he's a
catalyst in this situation we have a far
shot of a riot vehicle
there's protest signs like I mentioned
that are blaming insite we see dead
bodies on the ground and protesters look
like they're being rounded up taken into
custody and there's fires burning that
cuts to a shot of Caleb with Dolores and
we see the mechanical body there's a
crate there there's a shot of her
pulling on the synthetic skin but no
real explanation of why this is
happening or how the mechanical body got
to where they are one of the things this
episode is going to do is obviously fill
in the time right after the EMP went off
at the end of the fight in the last
episode beyond this shot here there's
not a lot to fill in those blanks either
way it seems like the prime Pearl is
probably back inside a mechanical body
then there is this shot of Dolores in
her blue Westworld dress she's standing
by a tree this could be her popped back
into a simulation except for there's no
black bars this could be something like
a dream it could be a lot of things I
don't really know what it is
then we see Dolores and Caleb advancing
through this building and we see that
they have a large group of people with
them backing them up everyone's armed to
the teeth and a lot of them are wearing
masks these are probably people
recruited through the Rico app outliers
as it were there's an overhead shot of
the insite building which makes it look
like that's where they're at I can't say
for sure that these two locations are
connected but there is certainly a gun
battle and Dolores and Caleb are
together here that cuts the Ciroc
holding a gun to Caleb's head and
there's a voiceover that says you think
you're in control you believe you're the
hero while he's talking we see char
loris walking through the gun battle it
looks like she's a hologram has her
image kind of glitches as she moves when
we saw her in episode 7 on the phone
with Musashi it was this strange shot of
her where we couldn't see clearly what
was going on she had like some burns
around the outside her face was repaired
it was curious here it looks like she is
a hologram so I'm not sure what's
happening but it's a really cool looking
scene at the next shot of Dolores she
looks surprised by what she sees as well
she looks concerned the way it's edited
were
to think she's looking at the hologram
of Hale and I wonder if she's surprised
that she's there or that she doesn't
seem to be on her side anymore that cuts
to a couple of shots of people firing
guns there's this sort of rage face
Delores firing off bullets then we have
Bernard and Stubbs looking surprised
that the man in black has pointed a gun
at them he told them that he was going
to kill them but I can't imagine that
that's actually gonna happen he's
outmatched by the hosts for one thing he
can shoot them but that doesn't mean
that they're going to die and this whole
thing just who knows what's going on
I mean Bernard probably has the key or
some other key pieces of information
that Dolores doesn't want to fall into
rocks hands they're in San Francisco so
they're on a different trajectory but
the man in black has this idea that you
know he has a role to play now he's
going to save the world and at least
from what he said in the last episode he
believes that's to destroy all the hosts
so I don't know they haven't really
given Bernard a lot to do except move
from point A to point B hopefully that
will improve in the finale we do see the
man in black in a different shot here
where he's not wearing the jumpsuit and
that's when he says I'm gonna save the
[ __ ] world there's a struggle with
Kaleb we see him turn and it looks like
this insight guy was gonna strangle him
they get into it and it looks like caleb
gets the upper hand we see this shot of
maybe our geing Dolores this must be
right after this other scene where we
see Maeve and Dolores fall from a bridge
they land on top of a car we see them
fighting in the street right after that
so the fall doesn't seem to have done
much damage to either of them we see
that Maeve approaches Dolores on that
same bridge dragging her sword on the
ground there's a shot of Dolores his
face in there where she's staring
straight ahead and then she looks up I'm
having trouble with the whole may versus
Dolores thing I mean they kind of gave
her motivation when the Connells pearl
was inside the simulation with her it's
just a lot of strange things going on in
that part of the story I think
established that Maeve can control the
host and has all these superpowers but
when she fights the Laura she just
decides to use a sword that makes for a
good action sequence I guess but Mavis a
central character in this story and
whether you like the finale of season 2
or not you think about when she got shot
at
I felt like something it delivered an
emotional impact of seeing her go down
I'm not sure that we have that same
feeling about her now based on what
we've seen her do throughout the season
she just seems to be a puppet I'm
guessing that there is an explanation
for that I'm guessing that she will
reveal that she has a plan that may
still include destroying the Dolores
because she just doesn't trust her but
in the end I just want them to get to it
I don't really need to see these fights
between Dolores and Maeve it just
doesn't really feel like an important
conflict in the overall big picture of
the story there's more shots of
protestors clashing with the riot gear
cops there's a shot of Caleb sitting in
a chair looking at Rehoboam we see Ciroc
and Maeve in front of him there's a
couple of guys with guns and another one
looking at a monitor off to the side the
screen is too small to make anything out
but we see their shots going off in
front of it in the flashes we catch a
glimpse of Maeve she might be chopping
at the person shooting or their gun you
would imagine that this is right after
we saw him sitting in that chair and
then we see one more time the mysterious
shot of Dolores hooked to these glowing
tubes there's also a shot of someone
wearing a glove grabbing a hand that
looks like it's probably made or Caleb
grabbing Dolores his hand and you know
that's the big question what's going on
here she's probably hooked up to the
machine I don't know why they'd have to
do it this way but if we think about all
the different possibilities that's
probably it they could be torturing her
but she's a machine so you would think
that if he wanted to get information
from a machine you wouldn't do the same
kinds of things that you do to a person
like torture so there's actually a lot
of possibilities there if she is hooked
up to Rehoboam that could have been her
plan all along she could have something
malicious that she wants to deliver that
way but we'll have to wait and see how
everything plays out so I'm gonna leave
it there I wish I could be a little bit
more excited I hope they do pull it off
I hope this will be a fun finale let me
know what you're thinking about in the
comments are you enjoying the season so
far
does this trailer get you hyped for the
finale let me know what you think please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon